well you said everything for me these
documents the state department has
prepared especially for
today's meeting it's impossible to read
these documents but we have a special
department which is headed by special
envoy of the ministry and they are
charged with studying of that and the
response has already been given i do not
think that we should additionally
comment on that
you just have to you know
look at these pages you can randomly
open a page and if you read what's
written there you see that it holds no
water whatever
it falls onto critical analysis
it's like experienceable in many cases
now
as far as ukraine is concerned we talked
about it once again our american
counterparts once again tried to
push to the forefront the issues at the
border between russia and ukraine they
tried to condition everything on the
knees of the so-called de-escalation
which has turned into some kind of a
mantra but i would like to reiterate
once again
at the end of our meeting we agreed that
next week the us is going to present us
with written answers to all of our
proposals
and you also
said in particular that ukraine has no
present represents no threat to russia
and i would like to once again remind
everything who analyzes our public
statements and our analysis
and i would like to say that never
before has russia threatened through its
official representatives the ukrainian
people
well
the western colleagues have taken
presidency under the wing
condoning anything he does
and presidency
said
that if someone ukrainian citizen
doesn't feel ukrainian and feels russian
uh pioche should get out of the country
and those
who who
fight the state terrorism in donbass
well he dubbed them as you might
remember not people but
you know specimens
so
we do not rule out that all these
hysterics
propounded by our western counterparts
six well if not to
provoke
some uh fossil actions by ukraine in
donbass
well then at least
it
seeks to
you know
hide caves
attempts to sabotage the minsk
agreements i see no other option
as far as allegations go we have
responded to everything and when someone
tells us that yes that's your territory
we recognize that but there are too many
troops but at the same time
they say that
it's not our business what the americans
do with their troops in europe and this
is something we discussed with anthony
blinken during our talks today and he
agreed that
the dialect has to be more reasonable
and i do hope that the emotions will
recede to the background even though
there is no guarantee that this is going
to happen